sehr geehrte Damen und Herren mein Name
ist Berthold Sandner ich lehre und
Forscher an der
Landesverteidigungsakademie des
österreichischen Bundesheeres genau am
Institut für höhere militärische Führung
und anlässlich 10 Monaten oder 300 Tagen
Krieg in der Ukraine möchte ich mich mit
Ihnen in den nächsten Minuten mit einer
kleinen Bilanz beschäftigen
wie sie hier an dieser Karte gut sehen
können sind es in etwa 17 % des
ukrainischen Staatsgebiets das durch
russische Kräfte besetzt ist die Front
von Kaki Bison hat eine Länge von etwa
1000 km das entspricht in etwa damit Sie
sich das vorstellen können da Entfernung
von Wien nach Paris und das zu erfüllen
und das zu erreichen wurde auf beiden
Seiten ein sehr hoher blutsollen Kauf
genommen nämlich von der Angreifer der
Seiten man spricht von 100.000
Verwundeten oder toten Soldaten auf
russische Seite aber auch hunderttausend
Verwundeten und toten Soldaten von
ukrainischer Seite die dabei gestorben
sind verwundet wurden ihr Staatsgebiet
zu verteidigen gleichzeitig ist aber
auch der zivile Blut soll extrem hoch
bis zu 16.000 tote Zivilisten und 14
Millionen Vertriebene aus dem gesamten
Staatsgebiet die Infrastruktur Schäden
werden auf 600 Milliarden Euro geschätzt
begleite Effekte sind Inflation
Nahrungsmittel Knappheit sie kennen das
mit den Exporten von Weizen
beispielsweise oder gestiegene
Energiepreise
die werden jetzt ein wenig in die
Zielsetzungen warum gibt es diesen
Konflikt und warum hat Wladimir Putin am
24 Februar den Krieg begonnen eigentlich
hat dieser Krieger bereits 2014 begonnen
als Seiten Russland die Griechen
annektiert wurde und wesentliche Teile
des östlichen was ebenfalls annektiert
wurden
was waren jetzt die Zielsetzungen die
Zielsetzung wenn wir auf die russische
Seite gehen war ganz klar die
demokratisierungsbestrebungen in der
Ukraine das Annähern an NATO das
Anlegung an EU zu verhindern role model
für das wie man sich von russischer
Seite die Ukraine wünscht ist Belarus
also eine belarusifizierung der Ukraine
ein geneigtes Regime von Russland
abhängiges Regime
Streitkräfte ohne offensivkapazitäten
und auf jeden Fall die Anerkennung der
besetzten Gebiete auf ukrainischer Seite
könnte man sagen dass strategische Ziel
ist klar überleben überleben um jeden
Preis aber wie Vladimir wo wurde mir
selenski das klar macht nicht zu jedem
Preis die Ukraine Präsident selenski
sagt unser Ziel ist eine unabhängige
Ukraine als Teil der westlichen
Wertegemeinschaft und auf jeden Fall mit
einer vollkommenen Integrität der
Staatsgebietes diese Ziele sind es die
wir immer im Hinterkopf haben sollten
wenn wir beobachten wenn wir evaluieren
dank dieser Krieg noch dauern könnte
weil ein Krieg endet normalerweise dann
wenn eine der beiden Seiten ihre Ziele
erfüllt und in dem nächsten Schaubild
wollen wir jetzt in den Februar
hineinsteigen genau in den 24 Februar
als dieser Krieg begann
Startschuss dazu war eigentlich der 22
Februar als Wladimir Putin die beiden
abtrünnigen Provinzen im Osten die
oblasten und dann jetzt als unabhängige
Republiken anerkannte und schließlich am
24 Februar fiel der Startschuss zur
russischen Offensive es waren rund um
die Ukraine in etwa 120 bis 150.000
russische Soldaten seit dem Herbst 2021
in Stellung gebracht worden und am 24
Februar erfolgte schlussendlich da
Angriff wie hat man sich das von
russischer Seite vorgestellt jedenfalls
ganz anders als es dann ausgegangen ist
erster Teil des Plans war ein ganz
rascher enthauptungsschlag in Kiew
Einsatz von Spezialeinsatzkräften
marine-schnell in die eigene Hand
Präsident selenski verlässt das Land die
Regierung stürzt und des ukrainische
Militär wird den Widerstand aufgeben ein
zweiter Teil dieser Operationsplanung
war es den Großteil der ukrainischen
streitkräftig die in dem Gebiet
eingesetzt worden wo seit 2014 dieser
gefrorene Konflikt war einzukesseln zu
trainieren und damit nicht für die
weitere Kriegsführung zur Verfügung zu
haben von ukrainische Seite und
sozusagen der dritte Frontabschnitt aus
dem Süden heraus aus der schon im Jahr
2014 besetzen kriegen ein Stoß nach
Norden und mit dem Stoß von Norden
gemeinsam die Ukraine in zwei Hälften zu
trennen und wenn das Ganze gut verläuft
vielleicht sogar ein weiterer Stoß bis
nach Moldawien in den Ort abtrünnigen
Bereich transistrieren
funktioniert hat das ganze nicht wie wir
jetzt in der Retrospektive gesehen haben
und eigentlich könnte man sagen nach
zwei Wochen war diese Art des Krieges
für Russland verloren und warum war das
so man ist von russischer Seite ganz
eindeutig von ganz anderen strategischen
vorhersagungen ausgegangen meist davon
ausgegangen Präsident selenski wird
fliehen man ist davon ausgegangen dass
ukrainische Militär wird keinen
Widerstand leisten und man ist davon
ausgegangen dass man wenn man schon
nicht begrüßt wird und ukrainischen
Bevölkerung sondern zumindestens nicht
abgelehnt wurden das heißt mit Mitte
März war dieser Art des Krieges für
Russland verloren und man musste in eine
neue Art der Kriegsführung gehen
ganz interessant zu betrachten sind wie
wurde auf internationaler Ebene reagiert
darauf es gibt insgesamt drei
Resolutionen der UN-Generalversammlung
zum Russland Ukraine Krieg das war die
erste dazu gleich Anfang März wo es
darum gegangen ist wird der Einmarsch
Russlands in der Ukraine verurteilt
gleichzeitig wurde gefordert die
Rücknahme der Anerkennung dieser beiden
Provinzen jetzt im Osten und ein
herausgehen Ausdruck keine und man sieht
hier doch eine ganz klare Spaltung der
Welt während Europa Nord und Südamerika
ganz klar für diese Resolution waren
gibt es in Asien ein sehr klares Bild
hier natürlich Russland dass die
Resolution ablehnt aber sehr viele
asiatische Staaten der Großteil die sich
in der Stimme enthalten haben ein
ähnliches Bild in Afrika
also die Weltgemeinschaft ist nicht
einig gewesen und die sich nach wie vor
nicht einig dabei den russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine zu
verurteilen
jetzt wollen wir uns kurz mit den fünf
Phasen dieses Krieges in den 300 Tagen
beschäftigen die erste Phase hatten wir
schon besprochen im Wesentlichen war
diese Phase im März vorbei und die
Russen mussten einsehen dass diese
schnelle Enthauptung der schnell
enthauptungsschlag Kiew das Besetzen der
Ukraine das fliehen der Regierung das
Einsetzen einer Russland geneigten
Regierung einfach nicht funktioniert
hatte
es gab dann eine Evaluierung
offensichtlichen Krämer der Kriegsziele
und Vladimir Putin gab eine neue Devise
aus nämlich die Befreiung des
Donnerstags also der beiden Provinzen im
Osten Lohan und jetzt als neues
Kriegsziel in dieser zweiten Phase von
einer sogenannten operativen Pause
sprachen sie sehen das hier an dieser
Grafik des Institut für das Studio vor
ganz gut zogen sich die Husten
eigentlich innerhalb weniger Tage 7 bis
10 Tage aus der kompletten Nord Ukraine
zurück das heißt aus dem Bereich und
Sumi formierten die Kräfte neu um sie
dann in einer weiter unteren Phase die
im Juni und August hauptsächlich war im
donpass zum Einsatz zu bringen in dieser
Phase juni August dobte dann wirklich
der Krieg in dem Bereich den wir aus den
Don was bezeichnen genau in diesen
beiden östlichen Provinzen um das neue
Kriegsziel und Wladimir Putin
zumindestens luhansk und dann jetzt zu
befreien zu erfüllen und den Russen
gelang es auch anfänglich hier recht
große Erfolge zu erzielen und am 4 juli
das ist eigentlich der einzige operative
Erfolg operativ militärische Erfolg denn
die Husten während dieser ganzen
Kampagne hatten gelang es wirklich den
gesamten Bezirk luansk in eigene Hand zu
bringen es vielen da die beiden
zwillingstädte sie wäre doch nett am 4
juli und du hans war komplett in
russischer Hand und die Offensive wurde
in die Tiefe des dornbas in die Provinz
in die Oblast und jetzt fortgesetzt wo
sie sich aber begann spätestens im
August fest zu fressen
die nennen beginnenden Stellungskrieg zu
verwandeln
damit kommen wir schon in die vierte
Phase des Krieges September November wo
durch war diese vierte Phase
gekennzeichnet diese vierte Phase war
durch zwei prägende Aspekte
gekennzeichnet einerseits die
ukrainischen offensiven und andererseits
die neue Art der Kriegsführung Russlands
als man erkannte am Gefechtsfeld keine
Erfolge mehr erzielen zu können und den
strategischen Hebel über die Bevölkerung
suchte nämlich den Einsatz von Drohnen
Raketen Marschflugkörpern auf dem
ukrainische kritische Infrastruktur was
gelang hier im September im September
gelang es im Norden im Bereich Tag gif
ganz tiefe Einbrüche in die russische
Frauen zu machen bis zu 70 km mehrere
Tausend Quadratkilometer zu erobern und
Mitte November mussten sich auch
schließlich die Russen im Süden in
kerson wo sie in einem großen
Brückenkopf mit 20.000 Soldaten noch
nördlich des nephra waren auf die
Südseite des netter zurück sind sehr
große Erfolge für die ukrainische
Führung
am 10 Oktober allerdings hier war der
erste dieser Einsätze begann auf
russische Seite eben diese neue Art der
Kriegsführung die wir bis jetzt kennen
wo sich sozusagen das Schwergewicht von
der operativen Einsatzführung am
Gefechtsfeld auf die strategische Ebene
verlagert und man über den Hebel der
Bevölkerung versucht einerseits die
ukrainische Regierung zu beeinflussen
nachzugeben aber auch Europa
möglicherweise zu spalten indem man
Flüchtlingsströme auszulösen versucht
und diese Einsatzführung ist nach wie
vor relativ erfolgreich der Ukraine die
Links das zwar 60 bis 70 % dieser
Drohnen Marschflugkörper und Raketen
abzuschießen aber es finden immer noch
genug ihr Ziel und in seiner
Wellenbewegung etwa alle zehn Tage
erfolgen diese sehr sehr schwerwiegenden
Schläge auf die ukrainische kritische
Infrastruktur die dazu führen dass
Millionen von BürgerInnen und Ukraine
Tage oder Wochen lang keine Heizung kein
Strom und kein Trinkwasser haben
wollen wir nun zur Phase 5 gehen
dezember bis wie lange sie auch dauern
wird ich habe diese Phase als
verlustreicher Stillstand bezeichnet was
jetzt zu erkennen ist dass es an der
Front vor allem im Süden in der Mitte
hier und auch im Norden zu einem
Stillstand gekommen ist denn Russen ist
es gelungene Front zu stabilisieren vor
allem ist es Ihnen dadurch gelungen dass
sie etwa 100.000 der Soldaten dem
September mobil gemacht wurden relativ
rasch in diese Frontabschnitte gebracht
haben dort ihre Personalzahl erhöht
haben und dadurch die Frauen
stabilisieren konnten wo tatsächlich der
Krieg tot im Sinne von gegenseitigen
Angriffsoperationen ist im dompass da
muss man ein bisschen unterscheiden
zwischen dem nördlichen und dem
südlichen Thomas im nördlichen dompass
sind es nach wie vor die Ukraine die
versuchen hier in die Tiefe der
russischen Verteidigungsstellungen
einzudringen wo ist die hier der
Hintergrund die russischen
Versorgungslinien logistischen Linien
die hier herunterlaufen zu durchbrechen
und damit die Logistik eingesetzten
kräftige abzuschneiden auf der anderen
Seite im Süden des dombas sie haben alle
gehört dann jetzt gut bachmut bachmut
einen Kleinstadt die seit Monaten ganz
ganz intensiv gekämpft wird wo die
Russen versuchen in die Tiefe des
Donners weiterhin zu drängen momentan
sind hier jeden Tag Gefechte zu
beobachten es gibt jeden Tag viele viele
Tote aber es ist eingefroren niemand
erzielt wirklich manifeste gebietgewinne
es gibt einmal einen Kilometer oder zwei
Kilometer Einbrüche hier und dort aber
im Wesentlichen herrscht Stillstand
wodurch ist das jetzt gekennzeichnet die
Einsatzführung einerseits weiterhin
durch die massive Zerstörung von
Infrastruktur das kleine Stadt bachmut
ist mehr oder weniger dem Erdboden
gleichgemacht wie so viele Städte im
dompass durch einen Grabenkrieg wir im
Ersten Weltkrieg das letzte Mal so
richtig geführt wird ein Stellungskrieg
und sie sehen das an den Bildern Schlamm
Matsch durch Artillerie zu Furcht des
Gelände verbrannte Bäume das sind die
Bedingungen unter denen die Soldaten
dort kämpfen und weiterhin dass der
tägliche Hebel erst in der letzten Woche
wieder der massive Einsatz von Drohnen
Marschflugkörpern und Raketen gegen die
kritische ukrainische Infrastrukturen
hier stehen wir momentan und in einem
nächsten Bild wollen wir uns anschauen
wie mögliche Militär strategische
Zielsetzungen jetzt
zum Jahreswechsel und in das Frühjahr
hinein auf russischer und ukrainischer
Seite aussehen könnten
hierzu ist es wieder notwendig sich zwei
Räume genauer anzuschauen einerseits den
Raum des don-busts den wir gerade
besprochen haben aber andererseits auch
sehr wichtig diese Landverbindung
zwischen dem don-bass hier dann jetzt
Mario Pohl hin zur Grimm eigentlich die
einzige Landverbindung der Russen zur
Grimm hin hier unten gibt es ja noch die
Brücke von Gerd und sie wissen ja genau
wurde durch die Ukraine am 7 Oktober
genau an einem Putins 70 geburtstag
wurde diese Brücke schwer beschädigt und
das ist halt eine sehr dünnese
Lebensader in die Griechen hinein wir
wollen hier im Norden beginnen und ich
habe jetzt erst die russische mobil
machen und gesagt etwas hunderttausend
Soldaten sind bis jetzt eingesetzt
worden bleiben noch 200.000 € von dieser
mobil machen und wir gehen davon aus
dass diese 200.000 Soldaten in der Tiefe
russlandsformiert ausgebildet
ausgerüstet werden und das jetzt so
mitte ende Dezember diese Soldaten
einsatzfähig werden momentan lasst auch
das Gelände und die Witterung größere
operative Bewegungen noch nicht zu es
ist nicht gefroren es ist noch nicht
genug gefroren auch die Logistik dieser
Soldaten für diese Soldaten lässt noch
zu wünschen über aber es wird
wahrscheinlich zu einem Einsatz dieser
Soldaten kommen sonst werden sie nicht
mobil gemacht waren und die logischste
Variante wäre diese Soldaten hier im
dompass einzusetzen über die genau über
dieses Gebiet wo auch jetzt schon die
russischen Angriffshandlungen sind im
südlichen dombas und genau die
Kriegsziele bleiben mir Putins dir dann
im März April genannt hatte die
Befreiung des dompers das heißt die
komplette Befreiung der oblassen du Hans
und dann jetzt wo einem noch ungefähr
40% fehlen zu erreichen also ein
tieferstoß hier in der ukrainische
Verteidigung Dispositiv nicht nur die
Provinz Johannes sondern auch die
Provinz doch jetzt komplett zu besetzen
und auch die ukrainischen Kräfte hier
zwischen den Norden und der Mitte zu
trennen auf der anderen Seite auf der
ukrainischen Seite wenn wir uns das
Anschauen den Raum hier von saporische
sie kennen das von dem Kernkraftwerk
etwa hier befindet bis dahin hinunter
was könnte die ukrainische Absicht sein
nachdem man auch weitere Soldaten
ausgebildet hat zusätzliche
Waffenlieferungen insbesondere auch
werden hier sehr sehr wichtig Panzer
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge Schützenpanzer für
die Ukraine einfach zu versuchen das
russische Dispositiv hier zu
durchbrechen und damit zu einer Sache zu
führen nämlich die Isolierung der Creme
also möglicherweise ein Stoß ein
größerer operativer Stoß aus dem Norden
und dem Süden um hier die kriegen zu
isolieren die russischen Kräfte zu
trennen möglicherweise gleichzeitig mit
einer erneuten Zerstörung der Brücke von
catch was dann bedeuten würde dass es
für die russische Seite gar keine
Landverbindung mehr zu kriegen kriegt
das sind mögliche militärische Handlung
so Optionen wie wir sie für den jänner
Februar März
sehen könnten natürlich gibt es auch
noch andere Optionen wie diese Kräfte
eingesetzt werden könnte natürlich wird
zurzeit viel spekuliert welche Rolle
könnte Belarus in diesem Krieg spielen
der Einsatz belarussischer Kräfte ist
bis jetzt nicht erfolgten wird von uns
auch weiterhin als relativ
unwahrscheinlich bezeichnet dennoch
könnten die Russen Belarus wieder als
aufmaßraum nutzen natürlich einen Teil
dieser mobil gemacht und Kräfte nach
Belarus verschieben und erneut eine
Bedrohung für Kiew darstellen davon
gehen wir aber zu mindestens derzeitig
nicht aus weil wir solche dispositive
zurzeit noch nicht erkennen
das bringt mich eigentlich schon zum zum
Abschluss dessen und was wir gesehen
haben ist dass dieser Krieg in der
Ukraine kein Krieg ist der nur durch das
Militär geführt wird wir sprechen von
den Machtmitteln des Staates beim
Diplomer sieht Diplomatie Politik
Information Militär economy und
Wirtschaft und was wir hier ganz klar
sehen ist dass dieser Krieg mit allen
Machtmitteln geführt werden
economy denken Sie an die Sanktionen
gegenüber Russland aber auch an das was
Russland mit
energieabhängigkeiten mit Lieferstopps
und so weiter gegenüber der Ukraine aber
gegenüber auch der ganzen Welt und der
Europäischen Union macht das Militär auf
beiden Seiten eingesetzt ein Krieg der
um und mit Informationen geführt wird
und dann krieg der auf politischer Ebene
natürlich auch geführt wird ein
klassisches Beispiel der heute für heute
angekündigte Besuch des Präsidenten
selenski bei Präsident beiden in den USA
und das bringt mich zu dem was unser
Artikel neuen Art des
Bundesverfassungsgesetz hat Österreich
bekennt sich zu umfassenden
Landesverteidigung nämlich zu einer
geistigen Landesverteidigung hier sicher
die ukrainische Bevölkerung
beispielgebend in dem werwillen in dem
Willen sein Staatsgebiet ihr
Staatsgebiet zu verteidigen in einer
anständigen militärischen
Landesverteidigung man muss ganz klar
sagen gäbe es des ukrainische Militär
nicht gebe ist die Ukraine nicht mehr
souveränen Staat auch wenn die Ukraine
natürlich von Waffenlieferungen abhängig
sind ist aber gäbe es kein Militär hätte
es keine Verteidigung gegeben und
Russland hätte durch eine einfach
anschließen können für das Bundesheer
bedeutet das natürlich auch auf diese
Entwicklungen zu reagieren und mit dem
Aufbauplan 2032 wird auch das Bundesheer
in Zukunft fit sein für die militärische
Landesverteidigung wirtschaftliche
Landesverteidigung in aller Munde
Abhängigkeiten verringern Bevorratung zu
führen zivile Landesverteidigung auch
hier natürlich Zivilschutz aber auch das
Wissen in der Bevölkerung und das was
passiert wenn Krisen sind gegebenenfalls
um die ein riesenvorsorge um Vorräte die
man zu Hause anlegen kann also all das
steckt in Artikel 9a des
Bundesverfassungsgesetz der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung und ich denke gerade
diese Bilanz die wir jetzt hin können
nach 300 Tagen Krieg zeigt uns dass
dieses Instrument umfassenden
Landesverteidigung ein Instrument ist
das klug gewählt wurde klug in die
Verfassung geschrieben ist und da gesagt
aktuell ist ich danke Ihnen für
Aufmerksamkeit